[Musique]
dès que la nuit commence à tomber
ulysse le marchand de sable accompagné
par son fidèle gros ours l'ami de tous
les enfants se mettent à parcourir le
monde
tous les soirs à la même heure portés
par leur petit nuage
qu'il pleuve ou qu'il vente ils viennent
rendre visite à leurs deux jeunes amis
petit louis et mirabel
c'est l'heure à laquelle les enfants
doivent aller se coucher mais mirabel et
p'tit louis sont parfois un peu
désobéissant et nina bien du mal à les
convaincre
fort heureusement l'arrivée du lycée de
gros ours arrangera tout jusqu'à demain
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi vous cachez vos p'tits loups et
mirabel vous savez trés mieux qu'il est
l'heure d'aller rollier alors sortez de
là je vous ai vu bonsoir petit louis
bonsoir me ramène dans ce paris là il
faut aller vous coucher
la journée est finie mais nina on n'est
pas fatigués et papineau et non nina on
n'est pas du tout fatigué tous les
petits enfants du monde entier vont
maintenant se coucher et vous aussi
mais où êtes vous encore cachés à vous
voilà encore un petit moment
li nina faire la toupie ma main non les
enfants de tomber de sommeil
roy c'est grave bonsoir
comment comment pas encore couchés
allons allons
on lit et en vitesse
[Musique]
voire mieux à bel au revoir jean louis
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voilà vous voyez p'tits loups et
mirabel sont couchés leur papa une maman
vont aller les embrasser et leur
souhaiter une bonne nuit
[Musique]
alors vous tout ceci elle évite au lit
et si vous êtes bien sage nous
reviendrons vous voir demain soir bonne
nuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]